Speaker 1: Let's go to Casey
from Kansas. Casey from Kansas,
you're next today. What's on your.
Speaker 2: Mind? Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Okay. And I think social murder
would be a better word for what Trump did there.
Speaker 1: Social murder rather than
genocide. Interesting. Okay.
Speaker 2: But. Back to my question,
I guess, please. Recently, Joe Biden and Eric
Adams. You know how they've pivoted on crime.
Kind of like the nineties. Tough
on crime era coming back again.
Speaker 1: I know Eric Adams did did Trump as
well. I'm not I'm sorry. Did Biden as well?
I'm not aware of that. What did Biden do?
Speaker 2: Well, you know how he blocked the
recent DC bill and he's been, you know, kind
of like going to the right a bit on crime.
Pretty much trying to. Set himself apart,
I guess, from progressives and other
Democrats who haven't focused on it as much.
Speaker 1: Okay. Yeah, I'll I'll I'll concede.
Speaker 2: That.
Speaker 1: But I'll concede that,
at least for the purposes of your question.
Speaker 2: Okay. But.
From my perspective, at least from the midterms,
it seems to me that the Democrats like Fetterman,
who didn't focus as much on crime, that they
didn't lose their elections, but the Democrats
in New York who kind of fearmonger over it,
I feel like they kind of campaigned against
themselves in a way by kind of giving in to, like
the Republican narrative on crime themselves.
That's interesting. There's anything to that.
Speaker 1: I think they're I need to look a
little more at the numbers and the specific races
you're talking about. But I do think that there
is a risk to the focusing on crime aspect to a
campaign, which is if the people you're talking to
don't actually believe that there is a
crime problem wherever it is that they are,
it can absolutely backfire. And one of the things
that we have determined is that if you zoom out,
the violent crime rate in the United States has
been declining for a very long time. Yes, there
were some spikes in some places over the last
three years at different times. But the narrative
of the dangerous blue states and blue cities is
certainly not true. At the state level. You see
higher rates of crime in red states, even within
cities. For all the talk about New York City,
the crime rate and violent crime rate in Oklahoma
City is higher. And so I think the risk which
you're astutely pointing out, is if it doesn't
resonate with people, if people are sort of like,
yeah, you know, I feel very safe and they're not
talking about anything else, I'm not going to vote
for them. That is a real backfire that can happen.
Speaker 2: It's another thing for me, too, because
even if people don't feel safe where they are,
because they're, you know, listening to 24, seven
media that's worried about crime. Who are voters
going to go for? Are they going to go for the
Democrat that is doing tough on crime lite? Right.
Or are they going to go for the Republican that's
tough on crime, you know, ultra or something?
Speaker 1: Right. So you're saying either way,
it's better for whoever is going
hardcore on the crime stuff.
Speaker 2: Well, I don't think
it's good for Democrats at all.
Speaker 1: It's not good for Democrats either way.
Speaker 2: Effective.
Speaker 1: I think that you're on to something. I
think that you're on to something. I think we can
probably try to verify this empirically. I don't
have the data in front of me. But yeah, I think
that you're absolutely on to something, Casey.
Speaker 2: Okay. Do you think it's a good strategy
for Biden and 2024 to focus on crime?
Speaker 1: I don't think no. So, listen,
Biden's not focused on crime. I agree. He's
talking more about it than maybe we expected
or we might expect or, you know, might
think he would. I don't think he's talking
about it so much that it's really going to be
detrimental in the way that you're talking about.
Speaker 2: Okay. Well, that's all I got.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you so much.
Very much. Appreciate the call.
There is Casey from Kansas.